hey what's up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
welcome to part five of the hackintosh
pro project the finale let's go
round one
so now the hackintosh pro is a complete
machine it is finished and in case you
missed the first three episodes of the
series which are annotated right there
or there will be the first three links
in the description below the like button
if you're on mobile but in case you
missed the first three the basic purpose
of this series was to create a beast of
a video editing machine that will happen
to dual-boot Mac OS 10 and windows and
there's been a ton of comments so this
video this entire video this finale is
meant to address all the comments and
questions that I've got and basically
wrap up exactly how this machine
performs and what it does for the price
you pay so let's go and get started so
as a refresher for the parts of this
build we're going to be centering it all
around an Intel Core i7 3930k 6 core
processor and that's pretty much the
center of the system and what we're
building off of so for that we have an
Asus x79 Sabretooth motherboard and we
have the gigabyte GTX 670 windforce
overclocked edition 2 gigabyte graphics
card we also have the courser h ati we
also have three vertex 4 SSDs and
numerous other various components and
accessories that we'll get to but
basically the parts to this build are
all linked down below and a lot of you
guys are asking for a total price and
that kind of fluctuates but I have a PC
parts picker link down below which will
give you a graph of how the total price
fluctuates over time all these parts
were put together in a fractal design
define our four case one of my favorite
cases of all time that I've ever even
seen period it's really good looking
case it's a silent inside case and it's
probably the best thing that I could
have possibly picked for this project
again opinions may vary but I love the
r4 so that's the case we use so in
previous videos in this series we've
discussed why exactly we have those
three vertex for SSDs these are all 128
gig SSDs the first two are going to be
used or are currently being used as a
Mac OS 10 raid 0 striped array and a
second drive or the second part will be
for Windows 8 so there's three total
drives two of them are a 256 gig raid
array for OS 10 and the last one is 128
gig Drive dedicated to Windows 8 and
because of this after you go through the
install process for Mac OS 10 you can go
ahead and insert the windows 8 CD drive
and install windows 8 on the third drive
just like any normal computer and now
every time you boot when you get
to the bootloader you'll have a choice
to boot whether you want to go into OS
10 raid or into Windows now one of the
easiest ways to get the most performance
out of your system is to overclock it
and that's exactly what I've done I went
into the BIOS just like anyone else
who's using this motherboard CPU
combination and I overclocked the CPU it
comes out of the box stock at 3.2
gigahertz with a 3.8 gigahertz turbo and
I bump that up to a 4.3 5 gigahertz
clock speed so now we're running at you
know four point three five gigahertz for
all the tests that we do we're going to
go ahead and show you guys the
benchmarks when I ran these benchmarks I
was at 4.2 gigahertz so I did eke out a
little bit more performance but the
benchmarks that we used were geek bench
Nova bench and Cinebench so I'm going to
go ahead and show you guys the benchmark
results we got for those first benchmark
here is a classic it's the 64 bit geek
bench - a fairly well-known and well
trusted multi platform tree the highest
2012 imac has been known to max out
around 13,000 points and that's where
the $2,500 baseline 2012 mac pro picks
it right up and as you can see here
without screen recording at 4.2
gigahertz I got a score of fifteen
thousand eight hundred eleven and I did
run it again off camera after
overclocking a bit more - like I said
four point three five and was getting a
score in the low seventeen thousand s so
that was pretty solid next up is
Cinebench which was a pretty fun
benchmark to test both the CPU and the
graphics card so for the GPU test we ran
through the animation with the car chase
scene and the reflections and physics
etc which was pretty neat and we got a
solid 34 frames per second which is
pretty good for a single card and then
the CPU test which was basically a
benchmark of pure raw data crunching
gave us a score of nine point one three
points so it's it's pretty good it's not
touching the systems with two GPUs or
two CPUs
but then again we wouldn't expect it to
and for the price of these parts it's a
damn good performer as you can tell last
we did Noah bench and as you may recall
the fastest Mac Mini in the world series
concluded with the finale similar to
this where we got a new event score in
the mid 900s but of course this is the
hackintosh Pro and it blows it out of
the water scoring more than 1600 points
and also showing our insane
read/write speeds thanks to raid zero
around 700 megabytes per second so
pretty sweet performer so now that we
know that it performs well what about
the experience well the OS 10 experience
on a hackintosh is one of the most
curious parts about this build a lot of
people want to know why you should get a
hackintosh
over a regular Mac and if it's going to
be the same experience
well I've owned a Mac Pro for a couple
of months and I can tell you that from
experience there is a lot similar
between a Mac Pro and a hack Pro and
there is also a lot different first of
all on the hardware side there are some
serious differences I'll start with
upgrade ability when you're going with a
hackintosh pro you have far more upgrade
ability than any other Apple desktop so
with the hackintosh you can change your
power supply at any time you can change
your RAM you can change your CPU
motherboard whatever you put in that
hack Pro you can switch out for whatever
part you want and get it working with a
Mac Pro you don't really see people
replacing the motherboard or replacing
the power supply those things really
don't just happen
usually the only things you replace in a
Mac Pro are the graphics card the RAM
and occasionally the actually yeah
that's pretty much it the hard drives I
guess there's also a difference in
dimensions but this depends on the case
that you pick for your hackintosh I
happen to pick like I said the fractal
r4 it's a very good looking case but
it's also a little bit shorter and a
little bit more squat than the mac pro
case which is a tall slim aluminum tower
with handles on top now you can build a
hackintosh in a magnate g4 case or a
modded mac pro case to fit your
motherboard people have done that but
personally I went with the r4 because
it's a like I said good-looking to me
but there are other options you can get
so the difference in dimensions will
vary based on what case you get so
another big difference between the hack
Pro and the mac pro is the i/o the
inputs and outputs that you get thanks
to the motherboard and there is a huge
difference you won't get nearly as much
I owe on the mac pro as you do on the
hak pro if you look at the back of the
Mac Pro you're going to get some USB
ports but not very many you get some
Ethernet some firewire you don't get
Thunderbolt on the new Mac Pro it's
weird that they still don't have that
yet but hopefully we'll see a new model
of the Mac Pro but right now it's really
really limited you flip it around to the
front and you still only have two more
USB ports and some firewire it's very
limited and then you have your headphone
jack
your microphone jack on the hack Pro you
have a load of i/o and you can see also
the new nock to a fan that I threw in
there but basically you have way more
USB ports you have way more ethernet you
have firewire you could get a hackintosh
Pro and use a motherboard with
Thunderbolt support I didn't but that's
an option for you if you want it but
other than that you get the point you
also have the front IO on the fractal r4
case so you have not only the power
button but you have four more USB ports
at least and you have your headphone
jack microphone jack and reset button so
there are way more i/o options available
with the hackintosh so processing power
how does it stack up well that you could
say that that's one of the strengths of
the Mac Pro it's not a weakness of the
hackintosh but the Mac Pro absolutely
flies ahead of pretty much any of the
competition in terms of processing power
you can throw dual Zeon's in your mac
pro it will be very expensive but you
can configure very powerful Mac to outdo
it so it'll crush benchmark so get
things like eighteen thousand on geek
bench you know nineteen thousand without
even breaking a sweat that being said
the six core 3930k is a very powerful
single CPU system and since we're using
a single CPU system with a single CPU
motherboard this is a really good system
I've been using it to video edit and
things like premiere and After Effects
and it works wonders and then there's
the graphics the Mac Pro has some
outdated graphics I'm going to be
perfectly honest the 5870 is more than a
year old and the applications were using
today are not that old and they need
more power than they did when the 5870
came out so when you're using a
hackintosh you get to pick exactly what
graphics card you want I went with the
NVIDIA GeForce GTX 670 that is
lightyears ahead of the Intel or the AMD
Radeon HD 5870 that was in my Mac Pro
another advantage to the 670 is the CUDA
cores so you'll be able to use the cuda
cores on the graphics card the basic way
of saying it is that you can offset a
lot of the power on onto the graphics
card that you would normally be doing on
the CPU and the graphics card is like
untapped power a lot of people don't you
know ever turn this on but when you turn
on CUDA you know After Effects flies
premiere is really smooth so being able
to turn these things on is pretty
important and you're supported with a
lot of new cards and last major
difference I'd say between the Mac Pro
and the hack Pro is the price
per spec that you get now if I were to
spec out you know this hackintosh again
the PC parts picker link is in the
description below the equivalent Mac Pro
is more than a thousand dollars more in
fact you can't get a Mac Pro for the
price that I built the hack Pro the
lowest Mac Pro starts at two thousand
five hundred dollars and even then you
only get I think six gigabytes of RAM
and a regular hard drive it's just not
the same with this you're getting a six
core 12 thread processor you're getting
32 gigs of ram you're getting a raid 0
array there's just no comparison you get
way more for your money and that is
probably the number one reason that
people buy a hackintosh or at least
build one over buying a Mac Pro and then
there are the little things like you
know the noise if you're video editing
and audio recording at the same time you
don't want the fans kicking in when you
don't need them so again the Mac Pro
that I had was pretty quiet but again I
went all out with the quietness with the
hack Pro and so we went with the
insulated our 4 case and we went with
the actually a new knock to a fan on the
back so that's the NFP 1220 millimeter
fan on the H ADIZ radiator so all of
these things are very very quiet and
that's definitely a pro the SSDs also
have trim support in raid 0 a lot of
people didn't know you could do that but
multibeast allows you to do that so
there's trim you don't have to worry
about these SSDs degrading there's also
the even smaller things like being able
to tweak the about this Mac section to
show exactly how awesome your specs are
there are instructions to doing all
these things all over the internet so
you can show exactly what the specs of
your machine are and show the case you
use and for any of you guys wondering if
stability is a major concern for you
once you get past the installation
process it's just as stable as a Mac Pro
from my experience I haven't had any
hiccups I haven't had any smoothness
issues frame rates or higher and
animations are just a smooth Mission
Control all the features work the same
way
stability stop not so for the Windows
boot a lot of you guys were asking about
the Windows install because I didn't
talk about it in the OS 10 install video
so the Windows 8 is what we decided to
go with for the dual boot basically you
get an optical drive and you boot up
just like you would boot a normal
computer to the optical drive and you
install Windows 8 to your SSD the single
SSD that we're having out
side of the raid array and that brings
us into vertex for Windows 8 super fast
SSD solution you get very fast
read/write speeds with Windows 8 even if
it's just one SSD and it's significantly
faster than you typically get on a hard
drive also I'm not a big gamer but a lot
of you guys were asking for some gaming
performance so I'll go ahead and leave
you with a little bit of some Max Payne
on the highest settings available on the
GTX 670 almost as much as I did
all right so popular question I get
about the hackintosh Pro is this setup
the actual physical setup that I have a
lease on my desk here I was tweeting
some behind-the-scenes pictures on you
know Twitter at MTV HD and some on
Instagram too but basically I'll go
ahead and explain to you how this works
because some things are a little bit
different all the way on the left here I
have the fiyo e 10 that's my amp and DAC
or digital audio converter I've done a
video on these already so that link I
guess will also be in the description
about why digital and audio converters
are perfect so these guys are was
powering all my audio who's always
powering these studio monitors and my IP
audio or my ath m50 headphones these are
our IQ audio studio monitors too so
that's what the audio is coming from the
m50 is by the way are pretty awesome you
should check them out if you haven't
already and then I'm using the Apple
accessories here so pretty much any
wired or wireless Apple accessories will
work even Bluetooth stuff so if you get
a little Bluetooth adapter you'll be
able to throw these in so I'm using the
Apple wired keyboard because I like to
be able to throw it into my BIOS at any
time if I want to tweak and overclock or
anything and I'm using the Bluetooth
Magic Trackpad as well so that's what's
allowing me to use Mission Control and a
lot of other features that you kind of
need the trackpad to use for those guest
use I would never use a magic mouse just
no and then there's the cyborg rat 9
it's not the best Mouse in the world
just because of the battery life but it
is pretty damn customizable so I
recommend it to those of you who want a
wireless customizable Mouse and a lot of
people also ask about the displays so
this is a dell ultrasharp 3000 7 WF p HC
as a 30 inch 2560 by 1600 display and
then over here is a 20 inch portrait
display it's again a 1600 by 1200 so the
reason I have this portrait is because
they match up perfectly so they're the
same height and they're the same
vertical resolution so I end up with the
rest
lucien of 2560 plus an extra 1200 and
then I get you know 1200 vertical and
1200 vertical here so when I move
windows across it doesn't resize or
anything and then the way I have my
workflow set up for Mission Control is I
have three spaces up here desktop one is
this for normal stuff desktop two will
be where I use premiere and then desktop
three will be where I have After Effects
and then I can swipe between these three
as I go you know I might be downloading
things from the internet and then I
swipe up and bring that into Premiere
and then bring that into After Effects
so the whole project cycle works pretty
well with that but that's just so you
guys know how I use these displays on a
daily basis especially when I'm video
editing so the elephant in the room now
is is this technically legal is it legal
to make this run OS 10 well technically
no this is not legal
Apple does not want you to do this at
all but I'm not responsible for anything
you may do as a result of watching the
videos in this series but if you're
watching a series you probably already
have a good idea of what you want to do
anyway overall though I'd say the
hackintosh pro project has been a
success it has been quite the workhorse
of the machine perfectly stable very
usable animations have been smoother
frame rates have increased buffer and
render times have decreased it's just
been an all-around great machine to own
and the satisfaction of building
yourself is kind of like Legos for
adults as dave dugdale has said having
the ability to pick all your own parts
and the satisfaction of getting it
together is really fun so that has been
it that's been the hackintosh pro
project i guess now we'll return to our
typically scheduled not really scheduled
but our normal programming of mkbhd
videos we got some more comparisons and
smartphone stuff coming up but either
way this has been fun guys thank you so
much for watching thanks for the thumbs
up and all the new subscribers as a
result of this project hi welcome aboard
and I'll talk to you guys all in the
very next video
thanks for watching guys face
you